-Our next guest
is a Tony-nominated
and Emmy-winning actress
you know from her work on the
hit series "Abbott Elementary,"
which airs
Wednesday nights on ABC.
Let's take a look.
-Ooh, this look is a slay,
Mrs. Howard.
It's giving grade-A baddie.
-[ Gasps ]
-Well, period to that.
I could never do this
on my own every day,
but it's nice to see
what I could look like.
Thank you. Oh!
Gerald, honey,
grab your gaiters
'cause we are
going out tonight.
'Cause Mama looks good, baby.
-Please welcome
back to the show
Sheryl Lee Ralph, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
-Thank you!
-Mama looks good in the clip,
Mama looks good here.
-Oh, God, I love you.
-It's just wonderful.
-Thank you very much.
-I mean, always,
always looks fantastic.
I'm so happy to have you back.
And I'm so happy to have
"Abbott Elementary" back.
This is season three.
Delayed.
-Ahh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The delayed gratification.
This was -- Everything
was shut down
because of the writers strike
and then the SAG strike.
It just must be
so lovely to be back
with this wonderful
cast and crew.
-Oh, my God.
You know, it was so interesting,
all of that time off --
which was necessary.
-Yes.
-The strikes were worth it.
-Absolutely.
-Go, workers! Yeah!
They were worth it.
But to get back and just be
there with the best cast on TV,
oh, it is just a blessing,
and I feel good every day.
I don't know about that 5:30
in the morning call, but, uh...
-They start you early.
Let's be honest.
They start you early.
And no respect for the fact
that you're here
in New York City right now.
You're gonna get
on a flight after this.
You're going to go back to LA.
Got to go to work tomorrow.
-Got to go to work tomorrow.
But you have to know, Seth,
I am making a great sacrifice
being here with you today.
Oh, I am, because, Seth,
there is a really big star
guest-starring
on the show this week.
They only had three hours.
Just three hours.
-Ah!
-Hit it and quit it.
And I've said to them,
"Guess what --
I told Seth yes."
-I'm so -- I'm already
so disappointed
that people are going to be
watching this big star
and every person is going
to be like, "She chose Seth?"
-[ Laughs ] Yes, I did.
-Thank you.
-You have to see Seth
in a crowd.
We were there
at the Emmys, right?
And when Seth is there,
Seth is like a charming magnet.
-Oh, thank you.
-And all the guy-guys,
they all want
to crowd around Seth
and just look at Seth.
And it's like,
"I want to be like Seth."
-Oh, my God.
-"Seth is a good guy."
And Seth is a good guy.
-Oh, my God. I mean...
[ Cheers and applause ]
You are...
I've always known
you are a fantastic actor,
but to see
what a great liar you are...
[ Laughter ]
Now, I -- you know,
you said it's the best cast,
and I truly believe it.
And I am sometimes
so jealous of the writers
that get to write
for performers like yourself.
Barbara, your character,
mixes up celebrity names.
This was another gift
you bestowed upon the writers.
This is something
you actually do.
They heard you doing this and
then gave it to the character.
Is this true?
-[ Sighs ]
[ Laughter ]
Okay, I will just say
this to you.
When you hear
the name Orlando Bloom,
tell me you don't see
big Black football player.
[ Laughter ]
-I do, yeah.
-Thank you!
-No, it does seem
like a left tackle.
That does seem like
a left tackle name.
-I'm telling you!
When I heard...
I knew for years
that Darren Star
was a young Black influencer.
I knew it.
When I was introduced
to Darren Star,
I was like, "Well,
where's Darren Star?"
I felt so bad to realize,
"Oh, my God,
this is not the man
I thought it was."
But I come by it naturally
and honestly,
and those are my mistakes.
And why it ended up in the show?
Mm, mm, mm.
But it was funny.
-There you go. It is funny.
-It's funny.
-It's funny every time.
The season premiere
is about Career Day.
You did not -- I would have
assumed, based on your talents,
that you knew at a young age
acting was your path,
but you actually thought maybe
you were going to be a doctor.
-You know,
I'm an immigrant's child,
and most immigrants, when their
children are born in America,
they want you to be great.
My mother was so shocked
that Barack Obama
was the first Black president,
because she swore
it was gonna be me.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-There you go. There you go.
She had high hopes.
-Oh, my God!
-High hopes.
-She just knew
it was gonna be me.
So when I went to college --
Rutgers -- I was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you!
Yes, yes!
On the banks
of the old Raritan.
[ Laughter ]
So, when I got to Rutgers,
I was a pre-med student, right?
And I thought
this was gonna be it.
But, you know, when you're
in these certain classes,
okay, you have to dissect
and cut things up.
And there, placed
in front of me,
is a huge hare --
H-A-R-E.
-Okay.
-Which is basically
the Easter Bunny on steroids.
-Did you get an Easter Bunny
vibe off it?
-Oh, my God, when I saw...
Well, actually, I saw this coat
that I really wanted
when I was small.
[ Laughter ]
But anyway, there it was
on the tray,
and they gave me
my first scalpel
in a nice blue velvet thing.
And I took it out
and I was like,
"I am not cutting up
the Easter Bunny!
That's not happening!"
So, I immediately
leave that class
and I go straight
to the registrar,
and I am going to
become a lawyer.
Somehow I get in
the constitutional law class,
and this lady, tiny little lady
with her hair in a severe bun,
and she just went
on and on about the law...
-It was a law class.
-It was a law -- Ah.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-And I was like,
"Hell to the no, no, no."
So, when I went back,
after giving the commencement
at Rutgers,
they said, "Constitutional law?
Tiny lady, hair in a severe bun?
Was that Ruth Bader Ginsburg?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
They did the math
and they were like, "Sheryl,
you walked out on RBG."
And I was like,
"Oh, my God! Yes, I did!"
But anyway,
that's how it goes.
-It all worked out.
-Touch! Yes!
-And you did, by the way...
You were not...
You were not
our first Black president,
but you did make
a little bit of history.
I've talked about this before,
but a couple years back,
I presented you with the Emmy.
-Yes, you did.
-Me and Amy Poehler,
for Best Supporting.
-Yes.
-And this was...
You were only the second.
Is that correct?
-I was only the second
woman in thirty--
second Black woman in 35 years.
-In 35 years.
-To be nominated and win.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And then something
very cool happened,
which was --
again, two in 35 years,
and then two in two years,
because this year
you're nominated again,
and our friend Ayo won, and you
got to celebrate with her.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you knew her,
you worked with her.
It must have been
a very special thing.
-You know something?
My father would say
this all the time.
To be the first is wonderful.
To be the second is great.
But once there is
the first and second,
what does it mean
if there's not a third?
-There you go.
-So I was very happy
to be able to see her
take that win.
I was like, "Go, Ayo.
You go, girl."
-We were very lucky to have you
at the Macy's Thanksgiving
Day Parade this year.
You were our Mrs. Claus.
And a role --
a role you were born to play.
-I was.
-Yes.
-And I am.
And I'm telling you, when --
you should have seen kids' faces
when they saw me,
they were like, "Oh, my God!"
They were like,
"Hi, lady! Lady!"
Oh, my God.
It was just so heartwarming.
And adults were like,
"That's Sheryl Lee Ralph."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, it was --
it was just the best day.
And I didn't freeze
too much either.
-That's good.
It wasn't too bad.
-It wasn't too bad.
-There you go.
-You see what I did,
though, to Mrs. Claus?
I had to zhuzh her up.
I said, cock that hat
to the side, baby.
-Yeah.
Let's get a little style.
-Yeah, let's get a little style.
They have fashion
in the North Pole, too.
-Thank you!
-What a delight
to have you back.
It is always
such a pleasure.
Can't wait to see
the new season.
-Mwah!
-Sheryl Lee Ralph, everybody.
"Abbott Elementary" airs
Wednesday nights on ABC.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."